[Musique]
pierre connaissa bonjour bonjour Nous
vous interrogons aujourd'hui pour une
chaîne Youtube qui s'appelle Serview on
aurait aimé avoir un peu votre point de
vue sur les récents événements qu'est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en
dire petit petit point biographique et
puis petit point de retour en arrière
bon moi j'ai travaillé une vingtaine
d'années dans les au ministère de la
Défense français sur différ
domaines poste tout tout sauf de
l'administration c'est-à-dire affairire
stratégique exportation d'armement
renseignement puis d'une manière
générale réflexion sur l'organisation du
ministère poste que j'ai quitté au début
des années 2000 pour diriger une société
intelligence économique pendant environ
8 ans et maintenant ça va je suis
retraité heureux parce que je peux faire
ce que j'ai envie de faire c'est-à-dire
en fait écrire je suis libéré de la
parole si vous voulez bon alors premier
premier aspect extrêmement important qui
va peut-être expliquer plus précisément
mon mode de
réflexion j'étais donc sur les affaires
stratégiques dans les la décennie 90 la
décennie 90 c'est le moment où l'URSS
nous fait la mauvaise blague de
disparaître he c'est ce que dit le
conseiller de gorbachov au sommet
d'Helsinki à
à au type de à l'équipe de américaine on
va vous faire la on va vous rendre le
pire des services on va vous priver d'
alors ça paraît une blague mais en fait
dans le système de réflexion stratégique
c'est évidemment un traumatisme parce
que comment voulez-vous réfléchir au
risque aux menaces au au défi quand vous
n'avez plus d'ennemis c'est-à-dire soit
vous avez le chômage technique donc vous
licenciez et puis vous pensez que les
budgets vont disminuer soit vous créez
de l'ennemi qu'est-ce que vous entendez
par créer de l'ennemi ben créer de
l'ennemi c'est ce que tout le monde a vu
paraître dans les années 90 c'est-à-dire
une réflexion américaine consistant à
dire consistant en particulier à à fusé
de la pensée comme par exemple le le
choc des civilisations comme par exemple
le le bouquin du tington ou comme par
exemple la fin de la fin de l'histoire
le bouquin de Fukuyama chaque fois c ces
thématiques sur lesquel je reviendrai
était amplifiée reprise et diffusé par
tous les médias de tous les pays pour
vous prendre un exemple le bouquin du
tinton a été traduit en 35 langues bon
or il posait une problématique sur
laquelle on pouvait avoir une distance
critique extrêmement importante puisque
ça supposait que il y a une espèce de
monde araboislamique qui était et par
nature agressif et c'était évidemment le
point de vue américain là-dessus mais à
partir du moment où le bouquin était
diffusé comme la nouvelle pensée
américaine ça formatait tout le débat
c'est-à-dire qu'on ne pouvait que se
positionner pour ou contre le bouquin
d'une tictone bon je prends un autre
exemp soit vous êtes avec nous soit vous
êtes contre nous oui c'est ça alors ce
qui est rigolo c'est que Bou quand il
utilise la phrase il transforme la
phrase de la Bible c'est-à-dire que la
phrase de la Bible c'est tous ceux qui
ne sont pas contre nous sont avec nous
et la phrase de bouche c'était tous ceux
qui sont pas avec nous sont contre nous
c'est rigolo comme changement c'est
antique c'est-à-dire que il reprenait la
phrase de la Bible dans la forme la plus
exclusive et celle qui était le plus de
nature à créer du
conflit bon et donc le cette autre
exemple qui voulez qu' est fascinant
c'est l'exemple du bouquin de Fukuyama
qui va être un des soutiens de bouche en
Irak qui va favoriser qui va soutenir
l'agression américaine en Irak sa thèse
était simplement la fin de l'histoire le
modèle démocratique libéral va être
triomphé donc finalement d'une certaine
manière il y a plus d'histoire bon vous
avez vu le succès de la thèse on peut
pas dire que ce soit effectivement une
vision prospective qui s'est traduite
dans la réalité bon mais ce qui m'a
intéressé beaucoup plus c'était la façon
dont à chaque fois paraissait un bouquin
américain vous avez une espèce de
mobilisation de tous les les journaux
les quotidiens les news à chaque fois
faisant des interviews des débats et
cetera sur C mobilisation ou une
propagande ben moi je donne je laisse
comment dire le je considère que les
médias sont libres de leurs choix
éditoriaux et donc que je les prends pas
pour des auxiliaires de justice c'est
pas leur sujet ils essayent de fait de
surfer sur ce qui est l'actualité
comment comment se crée l'actualité
après ça c'est une autre question mais
d'une manière générale à partir du
moment où vous avez un sujet qui fait le
buzz ben vous avez
immédiatement une reprise par les médias
bon donc ce qui m'a beaucoup plus
intéressé c'est finalement comment
fonctionne ce mécanisme de production
stratégique alors on est tous habitués
par exemple à parler du complexe
militaro industriel complexe militaro
industriel ça veut dire la conjonction
des militaires avec les industriels de
la défense qui seraient les faiseurs de
guerre or moi j'étais au ministère de la
Défense et ce que je constatais c'est
que les militaires étaient pas du tout
bellicistes d'abord parce qu'ils savent
ce que c'est que la guerre si vous
voulez et que par contre fonctionnait un
espèce de complexe militaro intellectuel
composé en particulier des singank qui
produisait ces fameux bouquins d'un
certain nombre d'intellectuels
médiatiques
de de service académique et puis
évidemment à l'intérieur des ministères
de système de réflexion stratégique
j'ouvre une parenthèse est-ce qu'au sein
de ces institutions vous avez vu une une
une conjonction de personnes ayant été
formées aux États-Unis ou ayant une
doctrine américaine pas à ce moment-là
pas à ce moment-là on était plutôt si
vous voulez dans une relève
générationnelle c'est-à-dire par exemple
les soviétologue étaient déjà en perte
de vitesse puisqu'il y avait plus de
Union soviétique et cela se battait
désespérément pour garder si vous voulez
dans leur espace administratif par
exemple les anciens pays de l'URSS
devenu indépendants gros débat
administratif c'est estce que les pays
d'Asie centrale nouvellement indépendant
doivent relever du monde turc ou persan
langue qui parlait ou au contraire
relever de l'exurss parce qu' ils
étaient anciens pays S soviétique voyez
par exemple donc c'était rigolo parce
que c'était une espèce de querelle
d'expertise mais qui était en fait un
enjeu de pouvoir comment est-ce que je
reste conseiller du prince non la relève
générationnelle est arrivée plus tard en
particulier c'est celle qui est au
pouvoir aujourd'hui c'est-à-dire de gens
qui ont eu cette espèce de
fascination de la puissance américaine
parce que la décennie 90 c'est la
décennie de l'hyperpuissance de de
l'unilatéralisme il y a plus de rival
cohérent réellement stratégique à à
l'Union aux États-Unis et donc à ce
moment-là une espèce de fascination sur
comment va faire le leader majoritaire
comment est-ce qu'on va le suivre quelle
position on adopte vis-àvis de lui et
cetera et la dernière survivance
goalienne si vous voulez de la
diplomatie française c'est la réaction
de Shirak refusant d'aller en Irak après
ça si vous voulez tout le reste est
balayé Sarkozi Hollande et cetera tout
ça devient une espèce de génération de
néoconservateurs en partie formé aux
États-Unis ou en tout cas ayant une
fascination pour les États-Unis et qui
vont suivre plus même encore que les
Britanniques si voulez les Américains à
peu près partout dans le monde peut-être
un petit mot sur les amerriican young
leaders justement à ce propos écoutez
c'est ce qui est très étonnant c'est que
c'est complètement intériorisé comme
attitude c'est-à-dire qu'il y a plus
aucune distanciation critique ils vont
pas dire j'ai été formé par le CSIS où
j'ai été formé par non pas du tout c'est
une espèce de comment dire c'est presque
des compagnons de route si vous voulez
comme on le disait à l'époque du l'URSS
c'est des gens qui gardent leur liberté
d'esprit qui ont leur liberté
d'expression mais qui sont totalement
American minded
aujourd'hui et on le on le constate par
exemple sur la politique à l'égard de
l'Iran qui devient totalement
incompréhensible c'est-à-dire comme ils
n'ont pas vu le virage américain ils
vont être obligés de rétropédaler si
vous voulez pour se dire mais après tout
maintenant on a besoin de l'Iran pour
résoudre la crise irakienne pour
résoudre l'Afghanistan pour résoudre la
crise au Liban et en Syrie et C donc on
est dans une situation où si vous
voulez la génération qui est
actuellement celle des stratégistes est
une génération qui est justement
totalement décalé par rapport à la
réalité alors comment se passe le
phénomène c'est assez intéressant parce
que par exemple dans les années 90 on
était donc dans la crise en youoslavie
la crise en youoslavie était
effectivement une crise qui nous
concernait directement à cause de la
disposition continental à cause du fait
que c'était quand même sur le territoire
européens un des pays occupés par
l'Allemagne qui avait le plus souffert
de l'occupation allemande qui avait eu
les camps de concentration et cetera or
ont retrouva en youoslavie un certain
nombre de comportements les camp
concentration serbees pour enfermer les
Croates les viols collectifs enfin on
avait tout ça B donc la ça concernait
directement les Européens et les
Européens à l'époque pensaient que une
alliance franco-anglaise suffirait à
calmer tout le monde à ce moment-là on a
découvert que ça suffisait même pas à
dissuader les Serbes de faire ce qu'ils
avaient à faireon donc là on s'est rendu
compte de la faiblesse à l'égard des
Américains enfin plutôt à l'égard même
d'une puissance moyenne comme la Serbie
et donc de la nécessité d'avoir un appui
américain c'est c'était l'époque où les
Américains étaient pas spécialement
Bellic c'està-dire que l'époque Clinton
était une époque où il a fallu les tirer
par la manche pour qu'il vienne c'était
pas il il considérait que c'était notre
affaire mais on était aussi dans un
moment où crise économique est dedans si
vous voulez tout le monde réduisait son
budget de défense tout le monde était un
peu réticent les Allemands en
particulier à intervenir militairement
et cetera ça donc il y a aussi ce choc
là c'est-à-dire le fait que si on n'est
même pas capable de gérer une crise
européenne du niveau de la crise
youoslave c'est que véritablement on a
deux options possibles soit on fait une
Europe de la défense mais ça devient un
débat philosophique à peu près comme le
sexe des anges ou alors on se met dans
le siillage américain et ça c'est
l'option qui s'est faite de manière
inconsciente et sur laquelle on a
ensuite continuellement décliné donc
l'intelligigen française ou
l'intelligencia
parisienne a poussé pour aller dans ce
sensl c'està-dire c'est c'est le
misérabilisme de l'impuissance c'est le
misérabilisme intellectuel c'est c'est
la le fait de ne pas vouloir se
soustraire du groupe
pro US je crois que non il y a eu
plusieurs choses d'abord il y a eu la
confrontation à la réalité constater
qu'on était pas capable de gérer en tant
qu'Européen une crise comme la
youoslavie c'est quand même un constat
dramatique ça voulait dire que sur le
territoire européen on éétait même pas
capable militairement d'avoir une force
d'interposition qui soit suffisamment
dissuasive n'oubliez pas quand même que
le siège de sarevo a duré 1000 jours
comme le siège de leningrade quand même
hein bon en d'utrre temps évidemment
déjà ce constat est terrible 2500
frappes aériennes bon alors ensuite il y
avait effectivement comment dire cette
espèce de gestion de la force qui
faisait qu'on voulait pas s'engager dans
une guerre on voulait en même temps
avoir une action suffisamment dissuasive
pour que les Serbes soit n'aillent pas
trop loin mais en même temps
rappelez-vous on a laissé faire gorasd
on a laissé faire des occupations avec
parfois des massacres le tout étant
évidemment une crise de la conscience
européenne puisque encore une fois
c'était un constat d'impuissance je
reviens puisque vous parlez de de de de
l'exyugoslavie qu'est-ce que vous pensez
euh des charniers de Timy soara bah ça
c'est plutôt une question qui concerne
les journalistes c'est-à-dire que quand
on est dans une situation de tension
médiatique comme par exemple les jours
qu'on a vécu la semaine dernière il est
évident qu'il y a une comment dire une
surproduction d'information j'étais
invité sur le plateau d'EUR 1 je crois
que c'était jeudi ou vendredi dernier
enfin quand il y a eu la les forces de
police et de gendarmerie ont décidé
d'attaquer les deux les deux endroits
tenus par
les par les terroristes
c'était extraordinaire parce que d'abord
le type de radio commentait des images
de télévision ensuite il demandait à ces
spécialistes journalistes de commenter
les trucs de télévision et puis comme il
fallait entretenir une espèce de tension
médiatique il passait la parole un coup
au correspondant qui se trouvait à
Massin un coup au correspondant qui se
trouvait à Darie et alors les types il
avaient pas grand chose à dire donc
celui de Darie disait ben oui il y a
deux hélicoptères qui sur non peut-être
trois non il y a peut-être deux bon ça
c'est exemplement de l'information qui
était une information de la tension mais
qui en fait n'apportait rien et Vincen
c'est encore plus caricatural puisque le
type de Vincen disait ben on a contact
avec la voisine qui est au-dessus
l'upmarché la dame disait ben écoutez
moi je rien à vous dire parce que
d'abord mes fenêtres donent de l'autre
côté puis ensuite les policiers m'ont
demandé de pas de fermer les fenêtres
ensuite il interrogéit le pompiste qui
habitait en face de l'hypermarché le
pomist disait mais moi je peux rien vous
dire nafrage le naufrage du journalisme
on on le note bien avec l'émergence
d'Internet euh la question que je me
pose c'est où est-ce qu'on va
c'est-à-dire on a une augmentation des
menaces les signaux faibles sont au
rouge on a euh des des des capitaines de
pédalo au sein des cellules stratégiques
et de prospective on s'engage nous
Européens dans des conflits libyens dans
des conflits syriens et on se retrouve
ensuite avec la bouche en cœur on se
prend des des des des répercussions et
des des attaques terroristes sur sur le
sol français donc vous êtes en train de
me dire que on n'est pas capable de
gérer le Kosovo euh qu'on s'engage sur
des guerres où l'enlisement était
prévisible et et et on a plus d'argent
oui le ce qui m'a beaucoup intéressé
notamment dans la fabrication de
l'ennemi c'est que je me suis dit
finalement quelle période ouvre-t-on
après 91 parce que finalement nayant
plus d'enemi pourquoi il y a-t-il encore
des conflits
et je trouve que d'abord la déclaration
de Bush qui a suivi le 11 septembre est
extrêmement intéressante parce que pour
la première fois il il déclare la guerre
à des concepts la guerre contre la
prolifération et contre le terrorisme
qui sont encore une fois pas des ennemis
qui sont des concepts et TER concept
dans sens spin doctor je crois que si si
vous voulez il formate la domination
américaine sur le monde c'est-à-dire je
vous donne l'agenda je vous dis qu'il
faut se battre contre le terrorisme
international c'est lui qui inventre ce
concept et puis il fait ce r tour de
passe-p stratégique formidable dans
lequel il dit la prolifération la menace
principale alors qu'il y a 11 saoudiens
sur 15 membres de la de l'atque du 11
septembre sur le l'IRAC et il dit que
les l'AC du mal c'est l'IRAC l'Iran et
la Corée du Nord l'Arabie Saoudite
personne n'en parle plus donc c'est ça
qui est intéressant c'est-à-dire comment
est-ce qu'on va concevoir un ennemi dans
lequel on va formater le camp occidental
en l'espèce et immédiatement la
déclinaison vous la connaissez invasion
de l'Afghanistan on peut aujourd'hui
dresser le bilan et puis immédiatement
dans la foulée l'Irak première fracture
alors l'Afghanistan est intéressant
parce
que pour peu qu'on ait un minimum de
connaissance historique tout le monde
s'est cassé les dents sur l'Afghanistan
c'est formidable les Anglais à la belle
époque du
colonialisme ils ont hein mais alors les
Anglais ils arrivent jusqu'à Kabou et
puis finalement voyant qu'ils peuvent
pas tenir le pays ils incendient le
bazar de Kabou il y a plus de bazar à
Kabou aujourd'hui c'est quand même
fantastique faut le savoir et puis dans
la dans le repli ils sont pris par une
attaque à la kber pass où est exterminé
la totalité du corps expéditionnaire
britannique sauf
un les afgans s'ent un type pour qu'il
aille raconter aux autres qui s'est
passé non non mais justement c'est la
première fois que la chose était crée
elle était pas créée par la la puissance
stratégique dominante elle étit créée
par une bande de vanupied qui était les
Afghans de l'époque les Soviétiques 10
ans sur place le résultat vous le
connaissez 4 millions de réfugiés au
Pakistan 2 millions de réfugiés en Iran
et finalement il quitte l'Afghanistan et
ne tenant absolument pas compte de ça je
suis à peu près certain que le monde qui
entourait bouche au moment de la
décision étaiit des gens qui n'ayant
jamais mis le pied de toute façon en
Afghanistan disaient mais Afghanistan on
va faire notre affaire tout de suite on
va attraperer ben ladan on va renverser
le Mola Omar et vous allez voir les
talibans vont être balayés c'est vrai
que les talibans ont étent balayés
le problème c'est queils étaient pas au
courant que la guerre était finie vous
savez c'est comme la déclaration de
George buou quand il y a l'invasion en
Irak la première phase phase
conventionnelle le régime l'armée de
Saddam Hussein est balayé et puis George
bouche fait ce fantastique discours sur
le porteavion disant c'est bon on a
gagné bon le problème c'est que les
autres sont étaient pas informés que la
guerre était pas finie et ils ont
continué et donc on est aujourd'hui pour
reprendre le cas de l'Afghanistan après
un bilan qui est particulièrement
catastrophique puisque ça fait 13 ans
sur place le même effort de défense que
les Soviétiques 6000 milliards 6000
milliards si on compte la totalité c'est
un point sur lequel on pourra revenir si
vous voulez c'estàdire la totalité c'est
compris le coûp des blessés le coût des
indemnités le cûp des veuves et cetera
et dans les 6000 milliards je compte pas
les vétérant
et autre aspect stratégique important
l'extension de la guerre au Pakistan
parce que les Soviétiques c'était
toujours interdit de franchir la
frontière tandis que les frappes de
dronees frappent sur le territoire la
zone tribale et donc l'extension de la
guerre bilan de tout ça vous le
connaissez c'est-à-dire un retour
probable des taliban alors le régime
najiboula qui avait succédé au
soviétique par pardon vous parlez pas
non pas du tout pas du tout pas du tout
et donc le le comment dire le najiboula
que les Russes laissent en place après
leur départ tient 2 ans on peut prendre
le Paris de savoir combien va tenir le
régime afghan
aujourd'hui bilan
catastrophique par pitié dame et par
grandeur d'ame je n'insisterai pas sur
l'opération française en Libye mais on
est exactement dans cette situation là
on va revenir sur puisque vous l'évoquez
BL
Bernard Henry levvi
bombardé pratiquement ministre des
Affaires étrangères
euh au côté de J McCain sur cette sur
certaines photos du moins pas sur
certaines photos mais en compagnie de
John mccin sur le territoire qu'est-ce
que vous en pensez ça que c'est alors si
vous voulez le je vous ai parlé de la
génération enfin de la du concept de
guerre qui était la guerre contre les
concepts ça c'était le production
américaine aujourd'hui on est obligé de
faire le constat qu'il y a pas de menace
stratégique le terrorisme n'a jamais
permis de gagner une guerre donc même le
terrorisme si c'est grave si ça tue des
gens et cetera ça reste que ce n'est pas
une menace stratégique de l'ampleur de
ce qui était l'Armée rouge dans les
années de 50 à 2000 bon donc on est
aujourd'hui dans une époque où si on
regarde l'ensemble des conflits qui
déchir la planète il y en a à peu près
400 mais comment fait-on ce choix pour
dire celui-là est grave celui-là n'est
pas grave intérêt économique pas
seulement pas seulement parce que
justement vous avez cette catégorie de
gens qui sont sont les intellectuels
médiatiques il y a des nouveaux si vous
voulez faiseurs d'opinion en matière
stratégique les premiers c'est les
intellectuels médiatiques dans la
catégorie dans laquelle entre BHL
premier point mais il y a aussi les
humanitaires qui vous disent je connais
les victimes donc je connais les
bourreaux et puis vous avez les
diasporas qui vont vous dire au nom de
la la souffrance que j'ai subi il y a 50
ans je vais vous expliquer pourquoi
notre pays doit s'engager vers telle ou
telle catégorie exemple si vous voulez
de diaspora c'est la diaspora arménienne
qui a réussi à faire voter cette loi
stupide qui fait que la France reconnaît
le génocide dans lequel elle n'a
strictement pas
participé pour aller dé donner des
leçons aux autres mais est-ce qu'on va
voter une loi sur le génocide des
Indiens par exemple il en est pas
question est-ce que les Algéries va
voter une loi sur le génocide des
combattants du FLN pour la France non il
en est pas question donc voyez cette
habitude de gens qui vont vous dire euh
la France doit absolument reconnaître
que fait que il y a une force de
pression la victimologie est un levier
important si vous voulez pour déterminer
les axes de la politique étrangère donc
si vous c'est ces trois faiseurs
d'opinion qui m'ont intéressé parce que
ceuxl ils s'adressent directement au
politiqu il passe pas par des analyses
disant invention le concept le plus
extraordinaire qu'on a inventé récemment
bon vous souvenez l'ingérence
humanitaire en Somalie oui l'ingérence
humanitaire c'était les chefs de guerre
P l'aide internationale à la Somalie au
pauvres gens de Somalie et donc il faut
absolument faire un effort de défense
pour
rétablir un pouvoir central qui allait
enfin gérer l'aide de population bon
plus plusieurs erreurs d'abord la
stratégie de l' moi parce que
finalement on a vu que si je prends à
distance si aujourd'hui tout le monde se
fout ce qui se passe en Somalie donc il
y avait bien un moment médiatique qui
avait suscité de l' moi et qui appelait
le politique à faire quelque chose c'est
en général c'est le petit enfant maigre
qui tend la main pour avoir un peu de
riz ça peut être ça alors vous avez
différentes stratégies de l' mois vous
avez les fmes viol petit enfant la
petites fille les enfants soldats et ce
donc ça c'est le canal médiatique par
lequel ça passe mais en même temps vous
avez là-dessus les intellectuels
médiatiques qui vont vous dire nous ne
pouvons pas ne pas la double négation
qui va expliquer qu'il faut absolument y
aller et donc on invente avec couchner
et betati l'idée la gérance humanitaire
alors pourquoi la gérance humanitaire
c'est très intéressant parce que les
humanitaires avaient le vent le vent en
pou depuis les années 60 depuis le
Biafra c'était le type d'action
internationale non étatique dans laquel
tout le monde se reconnaissait donc il y
a un capital politique qu'il fallait
absolument récupérer et donc qu'on a
inventé le concept d'ingérance
humanitaire c'est-à-dire associé du
militaire à l'humanitaire donc le le
concept de bombardement humanitaire
c'est ça pas seulement de bombardement
c'est-à-dire que il faut équip faut
comment dire associer les convois
humanitaires à des forces armées donc
c'est par que les min humanitaires ont
toujours dénoncé en disant mais non nous
ce qui demande notre sécurité c'est de
ne pas être armé c'est d'apparaître
comme non belligérant et donc cette
mixion qui a été principalement initiée
par couchner c'était nous allons
militariser l'action humanitaire bon le
reste vous le connaissez aujourd'hui
c'est que les humanitaires sont devenus
des cibles par la force des choses
puisque plus personne ne peut les
considérer comme indépendants alors pour
avoir écouté certains certaines
personnes un peu barbues qui se s'en
prennent au C humanitaire ils me disent
voilà on s'en prend à eux parce que il y
a de grosses suspicions d'injection de
de service de renseignement au sein de
ces uvres
humanitaires c'est probable c'est c'est
possible c'est c'est peut-être vrai
peut-être pas vrai je ne sais pas mais
du coup le seul fait que la suspicion
existe de même que sur les journalistes
la même
justifie le même type de comportement
d'hostilité et donc là où les
humanitaires se protégeaient justement
par leur pacifisme
affiché à ce moment-là effectivement se
pose la question de savoir quel va être
le comportement des belligérants bon
mais le bouleversement fondamental c'est
ce concept d'ingérance humanitaire qui
va se traduire en Somalie par le fait
que vous allez avoir des troupes
américaines qui vont débarquer en
Somalie en pleine nuit sous les flash et
sous les sunlight des journalistes de
télévision c'est les mecs rempent par
terre avec le visage tout noir et en
même temps ils sont autour il y a autour
d'eux des journalistes qui les filment
en direct pour qu'aux États-Unis on
sache que les j ils arrivve mise scène
formidable pardon une mise en scène
formidable oui mise en scène formidable
pu totalement contradictoire sur le plan
militaire donc on était dans quelque
chose qui évidemment à un moment ou un
autre finirait par clasher deuxième
aspect qui me paraît très intéressant
c'est l'absence d'analyse politique sur
la crise qu'on va retrouver en Libye
qu'on va retrouver en Syrie et cetera
pourquoi parce que l'analyse politique
suppose qu'on fasse un minimum de retour
en arrière avant de décider
or le Pô médiatique n'est pas le Pô
stratégique hein si vous un politique
est interpellé vous ne pouvez pas ne pas
par un intellectuel médiatique par des
humitaire et cetera il va décider dans
l'urgence alors pourquoi jeiniste sur la
Somalie parce la Somalie c'est
l'Afghanistan c'est le pays qui a
résisté aux colonisation exactement de
la même manière des structures tribales
tout le monde est armé et donc la
sécurité est assurée par votre tribu et
donc le colonisateur qui arrive il peut
être soit l'allié soit l'ennemi mais en
toute état de cause les alliances
varient il y avait un chef de guerre AF
qui disait une phrase que je trouve
toujours merveilleuse qui disait on ne
peut pas acheter un chef de guerre
afghan mais on peut le louer ce qui est
formidable comme phrase ça veut dire que
vous êtes dans un système d'alliance où
chaque jour se négocient vos alliés et
vos ennemis Somalie pareil donc pourquoi
le cas de la Somalie étaitil caricatural
ce pays qui a été reconstitué dans les
années 50 par jonction de la Somalie
italienne et de la Somalie britannique
est un pays donc où dans lequel
immédiatement il y a eu un coup d'État
militaire siadbé et siadbé a géré 50 ans
la Somalie en utilisant tous les moyens
de la force publique pour réprimer les
identités ethniques bon ça veut dire que
pour les Somaliens qui avaient réussi à
se débarrasser de Siad Baré leur seul
objectif c'était surtout pas d'état
central parce que si vous mettez un état
central ça veut dire qu'il aura les
moyens de la force et donc il va avoir
le même type de comportement que SIAT
Baré et donc nous on est arrivé en
chevalier blanc en disant on va vous
aider à reconstituer un état central les
types se sont dit ouais il y a un pe
toujours un peu de poignon à tirer donc
on va aller à la conférence d'adisabeba
mais fondamentalement leur logi propre
c'était comment est-ce que je reste moi
indépendant dans mon espace politique et
ça pose une question grave c'est que il
peut y avoir des territoires de la
planète dans lequel il y a pas d'état
central alors et donc vous voyez C cet
obstacle politique qui fait que on ne
sait plus faire dans ce cas-là je faire
je vais faire un parallèle avec la
Libye la Libye on va dire 6 se
tribus qui éta qui avait été fédéré par
cadfi après son coup d'État Kaddafi
tombe le pouvoir se décentralise les
chefs de guerre coup veulent avoir accès
aux ressources qui a sous leurs
pieds on est là-bas
ça commence à un peu agacer les
ressortissants en ayant du moin les
ressortissants ayant des accointances ou
ayant on va dire une vision respectueuse
de de l'islam voit des gamins se faire
bombarder sous le faux prétexte parce
qu'on allait en Libye là-bas pour aller
sauver la l'orphelin du Grand
tyran la guerre pour la paix HM ce grand
concept euh on est là-bas maintenant la
Syrie euh les gamins issus des banlieux
avec un pied entre deux continents euh
regarde la chose de façon lubitative
sauf que cette génération là est
connectée sur Internet et aussi est
influencée par internet et trouve aussi
euh les mensonges journalistiques un peu
difficiles à avaler
euh là on vient de recevoir des frappes
sur notre territoire hm hm on comprend
bien que depuis les 30 dernières années
la géopolitique de salon commence à
avoir des répercussions euh sur le
terrain les militaires qui connaissent
les Opex connaissent le prix du sang
ououis et les citoyens français
maintenant commencent à avoir le prix du
sang sur leur terrain on fait quoi bah
d'abord on s'arrête et on réfléchit
comme disait GB dans le temps hein c'est
quand même toujours utile ce qui est pas
l'ambiance du moment hein l'ambiance du
moment c'est pour avoir participé à un
certain nombre de plateaux de télévision
les hommes politiques qui viennent
prendre
acte de déclarations qu'ils vont faire
maintenant pour pouvoir dire dans 6 mois
je l'avais dit alors la thématique c'est
il faut augmenter les budgets des
services de renseignement de la police
de l'armée et cetera et cetera toute
chose que je ne discute pas mais c'est
pas ça que j'appelle s'arrêter on
réfléchit s'arrêter on réfléchit c'est
de savoir quelle est l'articulation
entre politique extérieure problème
d'intégration rapport avec la communauté
musulmane et cetera voyez ce que je
c'est ça qui à mon avis est la véritable
moyen de la réflexion ou un sourire
coûte moins cher qu'une balle c'est ça
bah c'est pas seulement ça c'est aussi
le fait que bien évidemment le passé à
l'acte violent est-il légitime bien
évidemment le fait de choisir des cibles
Juifs en soi est inadmissible mais
qu'est-ce qu'il traduit al c'est ça qui
est la vér question est-ce posez une
question ou c'est une question que vous
posez non non je me pose la question à
moi-même mais j'interpelle les
politiques français si vous voulez
c'estàdire qu'est-ce que à ce moment-là
il faut savoir qu'est-ce qui la
thématique psychiatrique si vous voulez
sur le thème ils son'en fout et cetera
c'est pas mon
problème donc un moment où il faut
s'interroger sur le rapport que la
société française a généré chez ces
jeunes voilà oui alors le on on on on va
élargir un petit peu le le le fait de
qualifier les terroristes ayant une
pathologie psychiatrique
euh je je trouve que c'est quand même
fort de café au vu de l'opération qui a
été montée c'est-à-dire que vous avez en
face de vous des gens extrêmement bien
préparés extrêmement armés lourdement
armés qui pratiquent on va prendre le
cas de l'hypercacher de vincè porte de
vincè euh c'est la même technique
d'intimidation que les attentats sur les
place de marché en Irak c'est-à-dire
jour de marché les gens viennent
s'approvisionner parce que bah c'est
jour de marché il y a pas d'hypermarché
là-bas et il frappent les jours de
marché pour terroriser la population
Vincen
samintandé la zone c'est une une zone
juive du moins à forte communauté juive
où tout le monde vit en bonne entente je
connais très très bien le quartier là là
on voit des politiques dire ce sont des
malades au lieu d'avoir une une
perception qui est beaucoup plus
structurée en disant voilà nous avons
fait des erreurs les gens en face se
sont organisés et viennent frapper avec
la psychose que notre propre violence a
généré chez eux parce que le fait
d'avoir quelques caricatures avec des
des des des fous cinglés qui viennent
tirer sur les gens on est au courant par
contre je reviens sur votre point de vue
quelle est
l'introspection des forces de
renseignement face à des politiques VAT
en guerre
hypécuritaire non je moi j'adhère pas à
votre question parce que c'est pas au
service de renseignement de interroger
sur le posture des politiques eux ils
ont un mandat ils ont une mission on va
leur donner si vous voulez un plan de
renseignement bon la question c'est
comment est-ce qu'il faut interpeller
les politiques pour que ils se livre à
ce travail que vous évoquez c'est eux
qui ont le véritable pouvoir alors on
peut jouer son rôle en tant
qu'inttellectuel on peut jouer son rôle
entre collaborateurs de services
administratifs et cetera mais il est
évident que il y a une part du langage
qui est quand on est à l'intérieur
de l'administration vous NZ pas dire à
votre Ministre excusez-moi monsieur le
ministre des Affaires étrangères mais il
y a un certain un nombre de de
thématiques d'interventions sur
lesquelles il faut revenir personne n'a
fait le officiellement regretter
l'intervention militaire en Libye par
exemple hein rappelez-vous c'était le
plus beau jour du monde du précdent du
précdent président et puis la Malie
c'est devenu le plus beau jour du monde
de l'actuel président donc on a une
espèce de triomphalisme dès que ça
touche aux choses militaires qui obture
si vous voulez l'esprit c'est ce qui
nous est arrivé après 1918 on avait la
meilleure armée du monde vous connaissez
la suite de l'histoire donc ce type de
réflexe il faut le comprendre
c'est-à-dire faut se mettre dans la tête
des gens il y a pas toujours le délai de
la réflexion alors pour revenir à votre
question c'est effectivement aujourd'hui
pourquoi il y a-t-il eu cette espèce de
viscosité vis-à-vis de la mobilisation
collective sur la liberté d'expression
sur la défense de Charlie et cetera et
pourquoi il y a évidemment eu ces ces
terrorismes
bon moi j'ai j'ai été à la suite d'une
conversation avec Vals ministre de
l'Intérieur je faisais remarquer que
c'était étonnant qu'il y ait pas de
politique de contre de contre radical
tion en France qu'est-ce que j'entendais
par là j'entendais par là que on avait
des problèmes avec une certaine partie
de la communauté musulmane mais que on
était toujours dans une espèce de guerre
de tranchée un coup c'était sur le voile
un coup c'était sur le la bourka après
c'était sur si après c'était sur ça et
cetera
bon ce qui effectivement l'a frappé
puisque d'un seul coup il s'est dit oui
c'est vrai que ça vaut la peine de de
réfléchir comme ça c'est-à-dire quelle
serait la politique
àont il se trouve que comme la politique
àont n'avait pas été réfléchie mon
rapport est sorti en il y a eu les
attentats en janvier donc ce qui était
mon ma réflexion à Mo devient une
réflexion sur
l'après pourquoi j'insiste là-dessus
parce que justement mon sujet n'est pas
comment est-ce qu'on fait redescendre
sur terre un transcendant c'est-à-dire
comment est-ce qu'on va faire
redescendre les frères Kashi si ils
étaient encore vivants pour les ramener
c'est pas par des cours d'instruction
civique et Coulibali c'est sûr qu'on lu
aura pu lui faire tous les cours
d'instruction civique on lui a même
permis de rencontrer le président de la
République c'est pas ça qu' l'a arrêté
c'est donc il y a une véritable problème
qui est un problème de rapport de la
société française avec sa sa composante
musulmane avec son organisation
administrative et avec sa politique
extérieure et donc c'est ces trois
volets là qui m'ont intéressé
c'est-à-dire où vont chercher pourquoi
ces types sont arrivés à cet état de
violence qu'est-ce qui les a amené
jusque là évidemment vous avez
l'interface c'est-à-dire qu'est-ce qui
se passe sur les sites djihadistes et
cetera et cetera et donc mon propos
n'est pas de dire les service de
renseignement devrait faire si la police
devrait faire ça et cetera mais mon
propos c'est de dire qu'est-ce que les
politiques doivent faire bon je vais
vous citer des exemples qui peut-être
vous é claireront mieux que mon propos
euh tous les grands pays occidentaux
aujourd'hui ont une politique de contr
radicalisation enfin surtout les
Européens les Américains c'est pas leur
problème en général ces politiques sont
nées après un choc traumatique attentat
de Londres en Grande-Bretagne caricature
de Mahomet au Danemark mort de Tho van
Gog en en Hollande à ce moment-là les
politiques ont été interpellés et ils
ont réagi intelligemment en se disant
finalement notre modèle est en
difficulté notre modèle d'intégration
est en difficulté donc il faut réfléchir
sur la manière de se comporter pour que
on contribue tous ensemble à la
déradicalisation à la
contreradicalisation alors ça s'est
traduit par trois choses première chose
un discours public c'est-à-dire il
désigne la cible par que la politique
française n'a jamais fait hein
rappelez-vous le Mali c'était le
terrorisme international la RCA c'est le
terrorisme international enfin il est
partout le terrorisme international ça
veut pas dire qu'il faut arrêter tous
les bas et tous les les cors hein c'est
pas le sujet voyez donc on dit pas
quelle est la cible euh
alors qu'en Grande-Bretagne en Hollande
et ca ils ont désigné pourquoi cette
désignation parce que la désignation
permet de faire comprendre à la
communauté musulmane dans son ensemble
que ce n'est pas elle qui est visée dans
sa totalité c'est une partie d'entre
elle dont on dénonce les pratiques les
idéologies et cetera extrêmement
important pour éviter l'espèce de
stigmatisation inconsciente dans
lesquelles tout musulman aujourd'hui est
en droit de se sentir audelà du discours
public une organisation une organisation
qui en général s'appuie sur les
collectivités locales pour pourquoi
parce que le type qui sait le mieux ce
qui se passe dans sa commune c'est pas
le préfet c'est le maire le maire il a
les travailleurs sociaux il a la police
municipale il a le Bureau d'aide sociale
il a le Bureau d'aide éducative et
cetera et donc il a le contact avec
l'imam il a le contact avec
l'association musulmane locale et cetera
ce réseau là est un réseau d'alerte et
ensuite le comment dire l'ét pourrait
fournir des moyens ça veut dire selon le
cas qui est signalé si c'est un problème
familial qui va expliquer la conversion
brutale d'un enfant ben ça peut être un
PSI ça peut être un imam ça peut être un
trava ur social et cetera donc l'état
fournisseur de moyens mais pas l'état
acteur ce qui est exactement le
contraire de ce qu'a fait la France
après le printemps dernier quand les
parents d'enfants parti en Syrie ont dit
mais nous n'avons pas d'interlocuteur on
a vu notre fils se radicaliser on l'a vu
un jour disparaître on est allé à la
préfecture on est allé au tribunal on
est allé au commissariat de police mais
personne tout le monde nous a dit je
suis pas responsable la réaction
immédiate spécifiquement français c'est
de dire bon c'est à l'état de s'en
occuper donc l'état c'est qui en France
sur les affaires religieuses c'est le
ministère de l'Intérieur c'est-àdire le
ministère de la police vous voyez le le
le yatusintérieur et des cultes et voilà
et donc le bureau des cultes qui est
justement l'interlocuteur normal de
toutes les religions se retrouve dans le
même administration que le bureau de la
police enfin que la police et que les
service de renseignement intérieur donc
ça va pas il faut à un moment se dire ce
n'est pas un problème de
délinquence ensuite on a confié
l'organisation et la coordination à un
comité qui s'appelle comité
interministériel de prévention de la
délinquence et on s'est appuyé sur le
réseau des préfectures
donc on retrouve tous les tropismes
français c'est à l'état de faer ce qui à
mon avis est une erreur c'est au réseau
public de s'en occuper ce qui est une
erreur bon donc le vous voyez pourquoi
je me situe en amont et et et
parallèlement à ça on voit on voit par
exemple le Qatar l'Arabie Saoudite faire
exactement comme certaines organisations
humanitair avec un drapeau vert fournir
des crédits fournir à des associations
de l'argent eux font ce que vous dites
mais dans l'autre sens B c'est ils ont
une politique locale ils ont de l'argent
qui arrive localement pour des projets
locaux ce qui permet aux gens
d'accaisser certaines théories et de se
radicaliser qu'est-ce que vous en pensez
alors pourquoi en France pourquoi en
France on ne suit pas les capitaux et
pourquoi en France on tolère des
capitaux de ce type là provenant de de
la vision la plus rigoriste de l'islam
c'està-dire l'Arabie Saoudite et et et
derrière derrière on a une relation qui
est complètement schizophrénique ou ouis
alors alors si vous voulez sur la
question de la désignation de la cible
je crois qu'effectivement il faut
revenir sur un certain nombre d'épisodes
historiques qui sont extrêmement
importants historiquement l'islam
politique c'est plutôt les Frères
musulmans début du 20e siècle
hassanelbana et cetera même si déjà il y
avait une espèce de légitimation duusage
de l'audience peu importe on est dans
une époque où cette violence était
surtout tournée contre les pouvoirs
locaux contre moubarakac et cetera et
ceetera
bon les Frères musulmans font une erreur
majeure qui est en par particulier de se
solidarité avec Saddam Hussein quand il
y a la guerre du Kuwait ce qui pour les
Saoudiens est le comment dire le l'état
de d'insurrection absolue bon
euh deuxième remarque également qui
prouve si vous voulez notre insuffisance
d'attention quand les les les Américains
aidaient les les mjahidin Afghans contre
les Soviétiques toute l'aide américaine
est passée par l'intermédiaire de
l'Arabie Saoudite et par l'intermédiaire
des services de renseignement
pakistanais on ne regardait pas ass mais
ça on le signalait mais personne voulait
y accorderimportance que toute cette
aide allait plutôt aux partis les plus
radicaux des des mjahidines Afghans
gouboudin matiar c'est que l'i donner
donner l'argent aux plus radicaux
absolument systématiquement ils étaient
mieux dotés parce qui évidemment sur
leur terrain de leur don sur le terrain
leur donner avantage et cetera et
deuxième aspect sur lesquel on sa'est
pas non plus attarder c'est que les
Saoudiens ont mis comme condition que
toute l'école doctrinale dominante au
Pakistan qu'il est anéphite qui était
plutôt une disons pas tolérante mais
enfin disons plus ouverte bascule dans
l'embalisme qui est l'idéologie
dominante de l'Arabie Saoudite et on a
vu 10 ans plus tard les talibans sur le
terrain c'est-à-dire les les étudiants
en théologie et donc ce sous-produit
qu'on croyait est une espèce
d'excroissance un absé on savait pas
trop bien non c'est le résultat d'une
stratégie qui est une stratégie dans
laquelle on raisonnait en binaire les
ennemis de nos ennemis sont nos amis
donc l'Arabie Saoudite étant contre la
c'est un ami or en fait l'Arabie
Saoudite avait sa propre stratégie et
même remarque à propos de ce que vous
dites c'est-à-dire à partir des années
80 80 90 les Saoudiens considérant que
il faut fournir des imams dans les
mosquées de France puisque le
gouvernement français se refusait à
prendre en compte cette variable a
diffusé un peu partout en Afrique en
France dans les pays occidentaux euh ces
imams W habit en l'occurrence salafistes
il faut les nommer par leur nom et on a
laissé faire complètement la seule
première réaction ça a été en fait
Sarkozi un beau jour interdisant un imam
invité pour le le sommet du Bourget pour
la rencontre annuelle du Bourget d'entré
mais tout simplement parce que quand on
regardait le site de ce type c'était du
l'antisémitisme le plus brutal et le
plus comment dire sans dissimulation
aucune et c'est ça qui lui a permis
d'interdire la venue de ce type bon donc
ce que vous dites c'est aussi comment
est-ce qu'à un moment on décline en
politique intérieure des barrage qu'on
ne veut pas prendre en politique
extérieure ce qui est quand même une
question importantei et donc aujourd'hui
désigné la princip c'est désigner ce
qu'est le salafisme c'est-à-dire c'est
une idéologie totalitaire he comme on en
a connu plein au 20e siècle simplement
celle-là elle est pas née chez nous elle
est née en Arabie Saoudite et quand on
si vous voulez si on veut défendre
l'Islam comme religion de paix et de
tolérance vaut mieux pas avoir l'Arabie
Saoudite dans son camp c'est c'est dire
que si l'Arabie Saoudite est dans le
camp américain comment ça se fait bah
oui je suis d'accord avec vous mais vous
voyez donc ce yatus le yatus le plus
évident étant la guerre en Irak où on va
combattre l'état islamique parce que il
décapite il coupe les mains des voleurs
il opprime les femmes et il interdit
autres religions pour aller défendre
l'Arabie Saoudite qui décapite qui coupe
les mains des voleurs qui oppriment les
femmes et qui interdit les autres
religion on pour on pourra faire une
autre émission sur le sujet où
d'ailleurs on pourra débattre de ce qui
se passe un petit peu dans le collier de
perle le le chapelet d'il où il y a la
sécurisation américaine qui commence
bien à verrouiller le le énergétique
chinois mais bon pour en discuter j'ai
une question concernant le après on voit
on voit notre gouvernement on voit
Bernard casenu on voit le président de
la République demander des des solutions
et dans ces solutions on a vu des
euh le patriotacte à la française alors
je je fais un petit rappel pour nos
auditeurs le patriotacte avec toutes les
conséquences que ça pu avoir aux
États-Unis sur les libertés publiques et
sur le le déploiement de la surveillance
donc maintenant on voit un patriotacte à
la française on voit une surveillance
sur Internet qui devient un copier-collé
de ce qui se passe aux États-Unis et on
bah clairement l'export du patriotact
américain sur le territoire européen
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez la
surveillance d'Internet la est-ce que ça
fait partie des politiques de
contreradicalisation est-ce que c'est
est-ce que c'est légitime est-ce que
nous la la la simple plebe nous allons
pas avoir des dommages collatéraux de
cette politique court-termiste qui
réagit d'une façon symptomatique
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez d'abord je
voudrais attirer votre attention sur le
fait que une politique de sécurité
intérieure est culturellement
extrêmement différente selon les grandes
démocraties bon les Britanniques
considérent pendant longtemps que
d'avoir une carte d'identité éit une
intrusion dans la privacy dans la vie
privée bon et leses américains pareil
considérent que c'est le permis de
conduire délivré par chacun des États
qui est la pièce d'identité pour nous la
carte d'identité ça fait longtemps qu'on
pense pas que c'est une intrusion dans
notre vie privée et un contrôle de notre
sécurité à l'inverse les Britanniques
avaient installer des caméras presque
dans tous les rues de Londres alors que
nous on se disait les caméras c'est une
surveillance inadmissible et cetera donc
chacun des deux a fait une partie du
rapprochement mais c'est pour vous dire
comme parfois les discours droit de
lomiste si vous voulez se rendent pas
compte combien ils sont euh com ils sont
très comment dire très relatifs si vous
voulez je vais vous en citer un exemple
parce que j'aime bien provoquer mais
j'étais à sarillevo peut temps après la
fin de la gure est-ce qu'on aura le
droit de provoquer un are tour bien sûr
bien sûr j'étais à sarayevo après le la
fin de la guerre le gouvernement central
avait à constituer une espèce
d'administration tenant compte de la
composante serbe de la composante
bosniaque de la composante croate et
cetera après une catastrophe humanitaire
gigantesque sortez du bureau dans lequel
j'entrais une association de sexuel
européen qui venait demander au
président de la nouvelle république
bosniaque quel est le droit des des
homosexuels dans en Bosnie aujourd'hui
si ce droit ne s'adapte pas au droit
européen nous nous opposerons à votre
entrée dans l'Union européenne vous
imaginez l'espèce de choc qu'avait ce
président se disant mais attendez j'ai
200000 personnes déplacées pour
lesquelles il faut que je fasse des
efforts il faut que je trouve de l'aide
humanitaire internationale il faut que
je constitue une administration il faut
que je constitue une force armée et ca
vous voyez le truc c'est pas que je je
veuille critiquer le droit des
homosexuels mais il doit y avoir une
hiérarchie qui correspond quand même sur
la question de sécurité comme sur les
questions de droits de l'homme aux
priorités qui sont les priorités
d'urgence donc sur le cas de la du
Patriote acte il y a deux volets dans le
Patriot Act il y a une partie intérieure
qui évidemment est une partie où j'ai
pas l'impression que les Américains se
sentent particulièrement surveillés hein
parce que
sinon les Américains été cortiqués non
attendez non non mais il y a deux choses
justement et c'est pour ça que je
voudrais insister là-dessus et puis il y
a une partie internationale et c'est la
partie internationale qui était la plus
contraignante parce que par exemple
patriote Act imposé que tout le trafic
de container qui était celui par lequel
on pensait qu'arriveraiit toutes les
menaces sur le territoire américain soit
le plus contrôlé ça s'est traduit
comment ça s'est traduit par le fait que
les
Américains limitent le nombre de ports
internationaux qui avaent le droit de
charger des containerss partant vers les
États-Unis bon pour la France il y a un
seul port qui a été autorisé à faire ça
c'est le Havre et avec présence de
doiniers américains sur place par
exemple deuxième exemple la liste des
passagers avec leur description leur
gographie et cetera c'est dans des
avions arrivant aux États-Unis donc la
partie patriote acte qui était la plus
scandaleuse c'était les contraintes
qu'on imposait aux autres en particulier
les toutes les données financières
bancaires à chaque fois qu'il y avait un
transfert d'argent vers les États-Unis
il fallait que la banque étrangère
signale d'où venait l'argent qui était
le propriétaire et cetera et évidemment
il y avait pas d'échange d'information
donc le patrio Act a été une formidable
captation si vous voulez au bénéfice des
États-Unis d'une grande partie des
données internationales dans le patriote
acte à la française je doute qu'on soit
en mesure d'imposer les mêmes
contraintes à nos partenaires donc on
est uniquement sur le volet intérieur
voyez c'est important comme dis vol le
volet croustillant c'est le volet
intérieur croustillant effectivement bon
cela dit si vous le décomposez par
morceau la surveillance sur Internet
c'est ce qu'on fait en matière de lutte
contre la pédophilie par exemple qu'on
va faire jeux je peux vous poser une
petite question là vous y connaissez
quoi en lutte sur internet en terme de
pédophilie parce que à vrai dire nous
sommes une chaîne de hackur ouais ouais
et et les pédophiles on les traque à
longueur de journée de nuit et on les
trouve surtout sans lancer d'accusation
dans le vent on les trouve surtout dans
dans des milieux où il y a de l'argent
où il y a du réseau et quand on essaie
un petit peu de les sortir du bois on a
beaucoup de boucliers qui se lèvent donc
l'attrac sur internet concernant le de
packet inspection tout ce qui est ce
genre de mesures
euh non non mais attendez moi je me
place sur le plan législatif d'accord
c'est pas sur l'efficacité du dispositif
le fait qu'on surveille internet comme
d'ailleurs on fasse des abus de comment
dire de droit de la presse après la loi
1881 les adaptations qu'on a fait
successivement et cetera moi j'ai pas le
sentiment si vous voulez que nos
libertés sont menacées quand on prend
des mesures contre le racisme contre
l'incitation à la haine raciale et
cetera sur Internet c'est un média que
vous connaissez mieux que moi mais c'est
un média sur lequel on peut
imaginer en tout cas de borné par un
certain nombre de pratiques législatives
ensuite que ces pratiques soient
efficaces applicables et cetera ça je
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du fait que ce
soit pas contrôlé par un juge ah ben non
non attendez on va pas parler du
dispositif législatif qui n'est pas
encore adopté mais vous voyez que sur
les écoutes problèm la loi de
programmation militaire est passée
l'article 20 est passé
euh on en est à faire de l'accumulation
de Data de de personnes avec des
logiciels prédictifs derrière euh vous
en tant que citoyen qu'est-ce que ça
peut vous faire ça ça vous interpelle ça
vous interpelle pas si je vous dis par
exemple pour 2,50 € j'ai accès à mon
fichier de carte électorale et sur mon
fichier de carte électorale je sais le
lieu de naissance h c'est-à-dire que je
suis capable de localiser par exemple
tous les marocains dans ma ville et
d'ailleurs tous les Marocains qui
gagnent de l'argent plus que la
communauté c'est-à-dire que si je vois
lieu de naissance parakeche dans le beau
quartier de ma ville je sais que ce
Marocain là soit est a fait un peu plus
d'argent que les autres si du jour au
lendemain je veux faire la même chose
sur les Juifs sur les homosexuels sur
les noirs sur les gens à cheveux blancs
avec une cravate rouge qui se mouche je
le fais en 48 he grand maximum je dirais
24 vous vous qu'est-ce que ça peut oui
mais est-ce que c'est internet lui-même
ou est-ce que c'est la
loi que s'apprête à voter Assemblée
nationale qui permet ça c'est ça ma
question est-ce que c'est l'outil ou le
vecteur c'est ça B oui c'est ça la
question que Internet soit aujourd'hui
une formidable outil de pénétration dans
la vie privée des gens parce que en
recoupant un certain nombre de fichiers
qui ne sont pas tous d'origine étatique
bien sûr cette possibilité d'accès c'est
une question qui vous concerne autant
que le législateur alors vous en tant
que citoyen ouais qu'est-ce que vous
pensez de donner des lames de rasoir à
un singe c'est-à-dire que la la la
situation économique les tensions
économiques sont très importantes les
les gouvernements changent mais les
outils restent les outils vous parlez
des outils législatifs les outils
législatifs non mais justement le débat
aujourd'hui il est sur l'adaptation de
l'outil législatif bon donc ça c'est un
point important moi ce qui m'intéresse
plus sur les questions stratégiques
c'est comment
pardon comment est-ce que aujourd'hui on
va se plaindre du fait qu'il y a une
ingérance informatique des Chinois ou
des Nord-Coréens alors qu'on a révél
avec l'affaire àange que le plus
formidable instrument d'écoute et de
pénétration informatique était américain
c'està-dire notre principal allié donc
ma question à moi en tant que
stratégiste c'est de me dire comment
est-ce que fait se fait à un moment
éteindre un débat qui me paraît
essentiel pour en faire naître un autre
qui me paraît beaucoup moins important
donc votre question c'est effectivement
ça c'est aujourd'hui qui est en mesure
de pratiquer une certaine régulation
démocratique sur Internet est-ce que
c'est le législateur ou est-ce que c'est
les hackurs on l' bien vu avec Anonymous
que c'est plutôt les hackur ça c'est
quand même un défi politique formidable
on voit bien qu'avec Assange aujourd'hui
Assange il est plus persécuté que
l'était abouatada ou Abou Hamza qui
étaient les générateurs du Londonistan
d'Illes
comment exp qu'on est qu'on a une
surveillance sur H
vraiment la chaussette que que les
frères Kashi é était laissé dans la
nature non c'està dire que là pour pour
Assange bon la surveillance est devenue
physique c'està-dire qu'aujourd'hui on
l'empêche tout simplement de sortir ce
qui est quand même ce qui est
intéressant c'est que on peut moi il y a
un sujet qui m'a beaucoup amusé c'est
pourquoi est-ce qu'on qualifie
différemment les mêmes faits bon si vous
voulez un type est enlevé en Colombie
ave demande de rançon c'est un une prise
de un kidnapping il est enlevé en Irak
c'est une prise d'otage il est détenu à
guantanam c'est un dénis de droit vous
voyez ce que je veux dire et les même
c'est les mêmes situations il a pas le
droit d'avocat il a pas le droit de voir
sa famille il pas le droit de passer
devant un juge et cetera or on qualifie
pas les mêmes choses des mêmes termes ça
c'est un truc extrêmement important or à
Sange c'est ça qui me paraît le plus
extraordinaire c'est que sans le dire
exactement on sent qu'il y a une
déstabilisation majeure des systèmes de
surveillance dans les pays démocratiques
parce que il a révélé quelque chose qui
était beaucoup plus important que ce que
propageaient les émires du Londonistan
et ça c'est quand même extraordinaire
qu'il n'y ait pas une mobilisation pour
défendre à Sange en disant mais attendez
que la Suède s'engage à ne pas
l'extrader vers les États-Unis puisque
c'est ça dont il a peur parce qu'une
fois qu'il sera aux États-Unis sera
condamné à 135 ans de prison et il y a
peu de chance qu'il sorte effectivement
au bout de ces 135 ans de prisons c'est
ça qui est le plus extraordinaire
c'est-à-dire que des états démocratique
aujourd'hui ne n'oppos pas à
l'extradition de Assange par exemple a
deux poids de mesure ah oui exemple
caractéristique les types du Londonistan
tous ces émires qui ont généré les
attentats de 2004 l'Angleterre refusait
de les extrader vers leur pays d'origine
le Yémen la Jordanie et cetera parce
qu'il disait qu'il risquait la peine de
mort formidable or on coopér avec les
États-Unis qui applique la peine de mort
vous êtes d'accord enfin sansreur de ma
part en tout cas c'est ce que j'ai vu
donc voyez bien comment on fait de POS
de mesure le comment il s'appelait
Rachid Ramda qu'on a demandé en
Angleterre d'extrader à la suite des
attentats de
94 dans les rues de Paris les anglais
pendant 10 ans ont expliqué que c'était
comp exp qu'il fallait saisir la haut
cours et cetera puis évidemment les
avocats de Ramda utilisaient toutes les
ressources de droit la dernière des
refus d'extradition était expliqué par
le fait qu'il risquait d'être torturé
dans les commissariats français voyz ce
que je veux dire j'ai jamais entendu la
justice britannique dire Assange il
risque d'être torturé aux États-Unis
donc on est vraiment dans un système de
deux poids de mesure et pourquoi est-ce
qu'Assange est un personnage aussi
comment
dire inquiétant c'est pas ce qui révèle
des pratiques qui sont les pratiques
également existant également dans les
États démocratiques où on se refuse à
démontrer que les États-Unis puissent
être un risque voire une menace pour les
autres pays occidentaux rivalité
économique connaissance sur les les
leaders politiques l'écoute de Angela
Merkel c'est quand même pas mal on n pas
l'impression que sur la vie sexuel
d'Angela Merkel qui l'intention de
surveiller c'est évidemment les
processus décisionnels c'est ce qui se
passe en Europe la Commission européenne
et cetera donc il y avait dans le champ
de l'écoute la totalité des moyens d'une
maîtrise du
monde qui a ouvert le le débat
l'Allemagne parce qu'on écoutéit son
chancelier c'est c'est un manque de
courage c'est quoi c'est c'est une
démission c'est c'est on pas c'est le
pouvoir de la non décision c'est quoi je
sais pas je sais pas franchement je sais
pas mais c'est vrai que c'est une
veulerie qui est quand même inadmissible
inadmissible c'est le terme la veie et
donc puisqu'on a tous ces moyens
là puisqu'on a tous ces moyens là on
peut donc finalement avoir une attitude
si on peut et qu'on fait pas
au niveau de la la sémiologie qu'est-ce
que ça
indique je pense que c'est une réflexion
stratégique à très court terme qui est
on ne se fâche pas avec le grand allié
c'est de la stratégie à très court terme
moi je me suis beaucoup intéressé par
exemple au à la façon dont si vous
voulez le général de Gaul penser sa
stratégie diplomatique de rupture
c'est-à-dire un beau jour il dit à ses
collaborateurs je vais reconnaître la
Chine populaire pensez bien qu'autour de
lui tout le monde a dire général vous
n'y pensez la Chine populaire des
Américains et C euh il a dit on va se
retirer de l'UT temp vous pensez bien
qu'autour de lui les gens lui ont dit
bon dans la foulée il a fait rapatrier
l'URE de la France et voilà donc si vous
voulez vous avez autour de vous un
certain nombre de gens il faut connaître
la sociologie des cabinets si vous
voulez un cabinet qui entoure un
ministre c'est une cour qui entoure un
roi et le cour est composé de courtisans
hein bon et donc vous avez quand vous
avez autour de vous des gens qui toute
leur vie disent ah oui monsieur le
ministre vous avez raison enfin pendant
les 2 ans vous êtes au pouvoir oui
monsieur le ministre avez raison
monsieur le ministre quelle bonne idée
monsieur ministre il y a un moment où
vous déconnectez avec la réalité la
grandeur degol c'était d'avoir toujours
cette réalité avec la cette ce contact
avec la réalité de la géopolitique du
monde bon aujourd'hui et je sais qu'il
avait payé de sa personne quand même
hein bon aujourd'hui on est dans une
génération à laquelle j'appartiens où si
vous voulez la connaissance du monde
quand on est dans les haut sphères de
décision c'est très simple vous arrivez
dans un pays étranger la voiture de
l'ambassadeur vous attend vous emmène à
l'ambassade à l'ambassade vous avez un
déjeuner où l'ambassadeur vous explique
le pays en 2hes ensuite vous avez vos
entretiens officiels où vous voyez vosom
qui évidemment vous disent tout le monde
accorde beaucoup d'importance à la
position de la France sur le sujet qui
nous préoccupe et cetera quelle est
votre analyse le soir vous avez un dîner
officiel le lendemain vous avez à
nouveau des contacts avec votre vos
homologues et puis vous remontez dans
l'avion bon alors petit en Champagne et
tapage sur l'épaule oui c'est ça mais
c'est surtout quel contact avez-vous
imaginez-vous que vous alliez en Israël
en allant àel à viv seulement vous voyez
ce que je veux dire et vous allez à New
Delhi en étant qu' vous allez enant can
da vous allez aux États-Unis en allant à
Washington coup vous découvrez qu' un
racisme aux États-Unis qui se traduit en
particulier par le fait qu'on peut buter
des Noirs dans la rue je vais juste
ouvrir une parenthèse la chaîne de
commandement au niveau des services de
renseignement il y a bien des honorables
contributeurs qui sont sur le terrain
qu' font remonter de l'information je
prends par exemple les révolutions
arabes vous parliez deune officine de
d'intelligence économique par pas
officine entreprise merci excusez-moi ça
c'est le qualificatif dégradant c'est
c'était pas la fonction désolé
excusez-moi euh il y a des gens de
terrain qui font monter de l'info des
gens qui sont connectés avec la
population des gens qui se baladent qui
qui qui vont serrer des des des pointes
de bergers pour savoir ce qui se passe
sil a eu des mecs passés avec des
Kalashnikovs il y a des gens qui font ça
il y a des gens qui font monter de
l'information ces gens-là commencent à
ranger un peu leur frein c'estàd que la
chaîne de commandement la remontée
d'information n'est pas respecté
qu'est-ce que vous en pensez de tout ça
écoutez je vais vous raconter un épisode
qu'on m'a relaté parce que je me suis
beaucoup intéressé à la raison comment
dire au début de la relation Fran
iranienne après la Révolution 79
rappelez-vous Romé é tant en France il
revient dans un avion d'Air France il y
a cette extraordinaire manifestation o
il a 3 millions d'Iraniens dans la rue
et cetera il éit qui applaudissent avec
le commandant de bord qui fait des
centresomé et CETA donc une espèce
d'histoire d'amour où tous les jours
devant l'ambassade de France il y avait
des glauls blancs et cetera bon et puis
en peu de mois on se retrouve au côté de
Saddam Hussein et on est le principal
fournisseur de Saddam Hussein donc
qu'est-ce qui s'est passé entre les
deux et en discutant avec quelqu'un qui
était à ce moment-là dans les cabinets
ministériel il me dit écoute moi je suis
arrivé en Iran en 78 quelque chose comme
ça
79 mon ambassadeur quittit son poste et
le chef de poste des GSE quittit son
poste l'ambassadeur le fait son
testament qu'il fait sa lettre si vous
voulez dans lesqueles il explique les
conclusions qui tirent de son séjour en
Iran et dans lequel il dit le chat
d'Iran m'a paraaraît un ses visionnaire
chef d'État visionnaire auquel le plus
bel avenir est promis et cetera 2 mois
après la
Révolution le chef de poste des GSE dit
l'Iran c'est un pays dans lequel il y a
1 % de francophone c'est ceux qu'on voit
tout le temps il y a 2 % d'anglophone
c'est ce qu'on voit mais un peu moins et
il y a 97 % de personnophon qu'on ne
voit jamais qu'est-ce qui se passe après
c'est là que c'est intéressant pour
répondre à votre question il se fait
allumer par le qu d'orsé qui lui dit ce
n'est pas la ligne officielle de la
diplomatie française il se fait allumer
par sa propre administration disant
n'oubliez pas que notre mission est de
fournir du renseignement brut vous voyez
pourquoi je cite l'exemple c'est parce
que la capacité d'un système à prendre
en compte quelque chose qui une rupture
est extrêmement difficile vous allez
expliquer à votre ministre monsieur le
ministre vous savez on est en train de
se planter
complètement soit c'est vous qui changez
de d'affectation c'est vous disparaissez
du cabinet soit votre Ministre est
intelligent il s'arrête il
écoute on fait quoi mais ce que je veux
dire et donc vous avez les deux types de
scénarios faut quand même se rendre
compte que si vous voulez il y a un
facteur que jamais les politologues
n'utilisent dans le l'explication du
monde c'est la bêtise des de
l'individu exemple vécu pour que vous
compreniez la chose euh génocide au
Rwanda le génocide éclate l'ambassadeur
sur place parle de rumeurs
bon on a vu la suite toujours est-il que
on se trouve dans une situation
internationale où les Américains ne
voulaient plus intervenir parce qu'il y
avait la Somalie l'affaire faucon noir
et cetera donc Clinton ferme les yeux
complètement les autres pays occidentaux
disent nous l'Afrique c'est pas nous et
cetera et la France qui avait été un des
pays qui avait le plus soutenu à
biarimana
comme c'est une période de
de non pas de collaboration de comment
on appelle quand il y a il y avait un
gouvernement de gauche et puis non un
gouvernement de droite et puis mitan de
cohabitation pardonation il se trouve
par chance que c'est un gouvernement de
cohabitation c'est-à-dire que miteran
qui était le plus africaniste si vous
voulez des soutiens d'abarimana se
trouve contesté par baladure et par Jupé
qui eux veulent absolument empêcher le
génocide de se faire donc voyez le le la
fracture interne au gouvernement
français
finalement Jupé et baladure l'emporte et
donc on met l'opération Turquoise en
place l'opération Turquoise consistait à
essayer de faire des zones sécurisées
pour que les toutsis restent encore sur
place puissent être protégé je le sais
parce que j'ai participé à la à sa
conception bon on se trouve un dimanche
après-midi dans le bureau du directeur
de cabinet donc dans le bureau du
directeur de cabinet c'était c'était
lesutard à l'époque que des chefs avec
la caractéristique en général des chefs
c'est-à-dire qui n'avait jamais mis les
pieds au Rwanda puisque évidemment leur
carrière était parisienne vous quand
même pas demandé aux gens en plus d'être
sur le terrain bon le chef de cabinet
milire ils sont pay combien ces gens-là
pardon ils sont payés combien c'est pas
très payé l'administration 5000 6000
quoi 5000 5
6000 non je pense pas je pense ça doit
être beaucoup moins que ça pour un
directeur d'administration centrale ça
doit êtreentour de 1500 € par par mois
je crois d'accord je attends je pense je
vous donne un chiffre comme ça mais bon
attendez laissez-moi réfléchir ça ferait
quoi ça ferait 20000 par an non c'est je
peut-être au dessous là c'est quelque
chose qui va pas je je vous donnerai les
chiffres mais on n'est pas dans les dans
les tarifs du privé hein d'ord et alors
donc le chef du cabinet militaire
explique le déploiement des forces
françaises qui doivent arriver sur place
pour sécuriser des zones alors il tient
un raisonnement assez simple qui est une
technique militaire il dit à Goma aux
Aïr il y a une plateforme aérienne donc
on va se mettre là et on va déployer
dans le nord du Rwanda parce que c'est
plus simple en terme de communication de
déploiement des troupes et cetera la
seule personne qui était dans la Réunion
qui n'avait aucune raison d'y être
c'était la seule personne qui
connaissait le Rwanda cétait un
universitaire que un type du cabinet
intelligent qui é en l'occurrence Jean
Christophe Ruffin avait amené dans la
Réunion donc ce type il écoute tout ça
personne avait grandchose à dire parce
que personne éétait capable de critiquer
la technicité militaire et lui il lève
le doigt il dit écoutez excusez-moi mais
si vous vous mettez au nord du Rwanda
aujourd'hui il y a plus tout si au
Rwanda parce qu'ils ont tous été
massacrés ils se sont réfugiés dans les
collines du Sud donc si vous vous mettez
au nord vous allez pousser pour toujours
expliquer que vous êtes là pour sauver
des TCIS mais aucun des belligérants ne
croira ce que vous es en train
d'expliquer puisqu'ils le savent et donc
ils vont penser qu'une fois de plus les
Français interviennent parce que ils
viennent essayer de sauver le régime
qu'ils ont toujours soutenu le régime
des utou bon ce type n'aurait pas été
dans la salle tout le monde aurait donné
l'explication que je viens de vous
donner parce qu'on suppose toujours que
les les décideurs sont rationnels on va
pas expliquer que les gens ne
connaissent pas le pays et qui donc vont
prendre une décision aussi importante en
terme humain mais simplement par bêtisse
et c'est c'est terrible quand vous êtes
politologue parce que si vous devez
prendre en compte la bêtise des gens ça
veut dire qu'une partie de votre
scientificité a disparu et c'est
pourtant un élément important de de deux
dernières
questions c'est justement une des choses
sur lesquell j'is rebondir est-ce que
c'est par la même bêtise en fait que
vous pourriez
expliquer une sorte d'idéologie à eu qui
nous qui continue de nous emmener dans
des des guerres qui ne sont pas du
tout jeallis dire d'un intérêt
quelconque pour la et l'Europe en
général bon je vais être plus poli que
vous disons que c'est une absence de
culture internationale on le dit comme
ça h mais en gros la question est tout à
fait légitime prenons le cas de notre
président aujourd'hui sa culture
internationale c'était d'appartenir à
l'international d'aller à des réunions
de l' l'international socialiste où il y
avait Mbarak et Ben Ali bon c'est tout
je vous ai fait le tableau rapidement et
donc cette absence de culture
internationale c'est en particulier de
se dire qu'un pays ça a une culture une
espèce de cohésion sociale un rapport à
la guerre et cetera qui fait que
on peut ne pas s'interroger on peut
s'interroger sur la nécessité d'utiliser
d'utiliser des moyens armés deuxième
caractéristique qui est un peu la
conséquence du tableau que j'ai dressé
tout à l'heure il y a pas d'ennemi
stratégique aujourd'hui et donc le
véritable critère de décision c'est
l'opinion publique intérieure si vous
avez un intellectuel médiatique qui vous
fait un pays un article du genre nous
sommes tous des Ukrainiens ou nous
sommes tous des Libyens vous le
politique il lit le journal le matin en
arrivant et il se dit ciel diable que
dois-je faire vous voyez ce que je veux
dire c'est pas un processus rationnel
c'est devenu un processus de comment
dire de géopolitique de
l'émotion le conflit le plus meurtrier
depuis la fin de la Seconde Guerre
mondiale c'est le conflit du Congo 25000
2 milliion et demi de morts 25000
enfants soldat esclav sexuel et cetera
qui parle du conit du Congo c'est trop
compliqué c'est des noirs on sait pas
c'est le M23 qui sa qui vous voyez ce
que je veux dire c'est donc pas la
gravité de la crise qui motive la chose
c'est la la gravité médiatique de la
crise et c'est ça qui est dramatique
hein et donc au lieu d'avoir une espèce
de C cette grandeur de degol qui pouvait
à un moment se dire mais la crise il
faut en tenir compte de ces
caractéristiques politiques avant de
décider là on décide en fonction de ce
que l'opinion publique va penser de ce
que vous êtes en train de faire est-ce
que vous croyez que nous devrions rester
dans l'
temps je pas de nous avez justement fait
sortir du machin de ce qu'il qualifia de
machin si vous voulez de nous y faire
retourner si vous voulez l'histoire de
l'OTAN est assez intéressante parce que
quand en en 91 donc l'URSS décide de
dissoudre en 89 décide de dissoudre le
PCT de
Varsovie les occidentaux avaient
implicitement accepté la dissolution de
l'OTAN ça c'est pas fait comme vous avez
pu le constater et puis surtout les
Russes avaient mis comme condition qui
effectivement qu'il y ait pas
d'extension de l'OTAN vers l'est vous
avez vu la suite donc on est dans un
système encore une fois qui ne tient pas
compte du tout de ce que pense l'autre
et donc on va le trouver comme on va le
considérer comme menaçant désagréable
agressif et cetera sans se demander si
on a nous-même généré cette agression
cette méchanceté cette réaction c'est ça
le processus intellectuel pourquoi parce
qu'on a inventé un truc formidable dans
les années dans les années 50 disons qui
s'appelle l'opinion publique
internationale c'est formidable comme
idée parce queà chaque fois qu'on parle
on parle au nom de l'opinion publique
internationale les pays qui ont voté la
résolution d'interdiction aérienne sur
la Libye c'est 9 % de la population
mondial 9 % les autres se sont soit
abstenu ont voté contre mais ces 9 %
c'est l'opinion publique internation
nation et donc à chaque fois on se
légitime si vous voulez en expliquant
que nous sommes là parce que nous sommes
le chevalier blanc porteur de toutes les
valeurs universelles et ce c'est ça le
processus intellectuel j'ai et donc
l'absence de culture internationale
c'est ça est-ce que vous pouvez résumer
l'opinion internationale
par alors ça va être difficile à
formuler
ça par une min sa forme de
gens on va dire bercé par le le jeu
hollywoodien du du Cheval Blanc du
gentil américain qui vient sauver la
petite fille avec un ce même système de
valeur projetée donc c'est c'est on va
dire 9 % pour être un peu vulgaire 9% de
Bobo de l'opinion internationale qui
vote ayant un pouvoir d'achat pouvant
permettre de faire rlire X ou Y
dirigeants est-ce que c'est est-ce que
c'est le le bras armé de nos politiques
cette fameuse opinion internationale
qu'on peut manipuler corsam on les
abrevons soit de de propos anxiogène euh
soit de de bon sentiment bon sentiment
voà écoutez en tout cas ça pose une
question qui mériterait une analyse plus
approfondie c'est-à-dire
qu'effectivement mais vous avez raison
de le formuler enfin de de formuler la
question euh moi je suis obligé de
constater on le voit bien que on
retrouve le même personnage BHL qui
déclenche la guerre en Libye et puis qui
ensuite ramène les gens du le nouveau
pouvoir
ukrainien dans le nouveau président au
nouveau président donc il y a quelque
chose qui quand même mérite qu'on
s'interroge sur mais qui fait la
notoriété de ces individus h alors ce
qui est intéressant c'est que vous avez
chez un certain nombre d'intellectuels
des positions de pouvoir c'est-à-dire
quand vous avez un même individu qui est
au conseil de surveillance de la 7 qui
est au comité d'électeurs du monde et
cetera et cetera vous avez vu les
nouveaux cha Gard oui oui je l'ai vu ou
qu'est-ce que vous avez pensé ah j'ai
trouvé ça très bien oua vous le REC on
le constate d'ailleurs sur les plateaux
télé recommandez ah ben oui oui bien sûr
sû moi je l'ai vu j'ai trouvé ça est-ce
que vous connaissez Naomi clin ça me dit
quelque chose la stratégie du choc je
connais pas ça tiens je vous le
conseille vivement et je vous propose
qu'on refasse émission sur ce sur ce
concept une dernière question juste pour
terminer sur votre sujet dans la
stratégie de de séduction que vous
évoquiez c'est-à-dire le rapport aux
États-Unis juste deux ou trois choses
pour que vos auditeurs retiennent ces
choses en tête le rapport à la guerre
les Américains ont perdu moins de monde
dans tous les conflits du 20e siècle que
de morts pour des raisons de détention
d'armes à l'intérieur des États-Unis bon
quand vous avez d'un côté 20 millions de
morts en Russie et que vous avez moins
d'un million de morts au état États Unis
le rapport à la guerre n'est pas le même
parce que vous n'z jamaisérence à 3945
oui à 39 non non toutes les guerres du
du 20e siècle he toutes les guerres du
20e siècle y compris le Vietnam il
compris 148 d'ord il y a eu à peu près
190000 morts pendant la Seconde Guerre
mondiale américain et il y a eu 169000
morts belges combien de morts russes et
20 millions très bien bon et donc vous
avez quelque chose qui est quelque chose
d'assez fascinant c'est-à-dire quand la
guerre ne s'est jamais passé sur votre
territoire que vous ne savez pas ce que
c'est qu'une ville bombardée vous savez
pas ce que c'est que des tickets de
rationnement vous savez pas ce que c'est
que de faire des que à des points d'eau
et que votre a toujours été médiatisé
par Hollywood votre rapport à la guerre
et à la décision de l'intervention armée
est complètement différent de celui des
Russes bon j'ai écouté une interview de
Jean Gabin vous savez que Jean Gabin
était à l'époque à Hollywood quand la
France perd la guerre et que finalement
il décide de rejoindre Londres pour
s'engager dans les Forces françaises
libres il a fait discrètement il s'en
est pas vanté il est parti il est allé
au consulat de Grande-Bretagne il a
demandé à partir vers Londres il se
trouve dans un bateau de ces convois
vous savez de l'Atlantique Nord qui
était sous le feu des sous-marins des
torpilles des sous-marins sous le feu
des bombardi alon rant d'action allemand
et cetera et il serrait les fesses parce
que il avait peur comme c'était pas
possible il avait vu juste avant de
partir un film sur ses convoi de
l'Atlantique nord et un des capitaines
de ces bateaux était unfrey Bogard et un
frrey Bogard était impérial dans la
tempête évidemment c'està dire ça tirait
de tous les côtés mais il était là il
gardait son sang froid ilit et Gabin se
disait mais quel con ce Bogard quel con
ce beogard et c'est ça la guerre quand
vous l'avez toujours vu à travers le
cinéma vous ne pouvez pas avoir le même
rapport à la guerre ça c'est une chose
ouais mais maintenant on a jackes Bower
vous connaissez Jack Bower autre aspect
c'est celui-là c'est qu'aujourd'hui
chaque semaine vous avez un super-héros
américain qui sauve la planète alors moi
j'ai proposé justement dans la
fabrication de l'enemi que nous on a des
super intellectuel ou la BHL mais dopé
ou pas dopé ah non non non super
intellectuel c'est les P concept c'est
le nouveau concept c'est le nouveau
moyen d'armement moi j'ai proposé qu'on
fasse un jumelage BHL stalon oui et
qu'on les envoie en Afghanistan à eu
jage sur le terme génétique ou non non
non non moi je je veux pas me faire de
manipulation génétique mais BHL a écrit
deux articles que j'ai retrouvé dans le
point expliquant comment il fallait
résoudre la crise afghane et BHL je me
sers de cet argument pour les cours que
je fais à Science Po j'ai acheté Rambo 2
Rambo 2 c'est moment où il revient au
Vietnam parce que il y a toujours des
pilotes américains emprisonnés par ces
salotes vietnami et C il y va on va le
chercher lui évidemment et il dit cette
fois on y va pour gagner argument
classique de l'extrême droite si on a
perdu c'est la faute de ses bureaucrates
et de ses politiciens et dans le film il
tue 72 types 72 alors évidemment il est
tu tout seul hein je veux dire à l' à
l'arc au pistolet à la mitrailleuse à la
doucette du regard c'est non non non non
parce que quand même à un moment il se
coupe à la main ouais quand même et donc
il faut que l'héroïne le soigne mais
comme l'héroïne est une aasienne il faut
qu'elle meure he il faut pas qu'il
revienne faut pas qu'il ramène une femme
là-bas bon mais imaginez une minute
qu'on fasse un film comme ça sur
l'Algérie un mec qui dise on va
retourner en Algérie cette fois on y va
pour gagner et qui tue 72 algériens vous
imaginez le scandale politique que ça
ferait en France et nous on prend ça oui
mais c'est pas grave c'est un film
d'aventure voyez le le décalage
psychologique que ça le rapport à la
violence en particulier le rapport à la
violence bien sûr c'est le héros
américain est évidemment le héros le bon
héros qui est plus musclé que le mauvais
héros que le que le méchant allez on va
on va terminer l'interview je vais vous
poser juste deux petites questions la
première ça consiste je vous cite un mot
et vous me dites du tacotac à quoi ça
vous fait penser le Barine barag c'est
l'exemple même du trou noir de la
réflexion stratégique occidentale occupé
par les soouiens qui on réprimé la
majorité de la population chiide pour
rétablir une monarchie sunite donc ça
fait partie de ces interventions
extérieures de nos alliés pour lesqueles
on dont on parle pas Saoudite Arabie
Saoudite c'est à peu près la Corée du
Nord intellectuelle c'est-à-dire que
c'est le même état d'esprit interdiction
de tous il faut être aller en Arabie
Saoudite pour voir ce que c'est hein je
veux dire la seule distraction c'est le
centre commercial Bachar alAssad euh je
termine juste sur l'Arabie Saoudite et
donc sur l'Arabie Saoudite c'est un
fantastique comment dire c'est un
fantastique comment dire trou noir
encore une fois de la pensé stratégique
occidentale achat euh Bachar alAssad non
non non achat en France par les capitaux
du
Qatar moi ça ne me gêne pas à partir du
moment où on les gère c'est-à-dire par
exemple quand le Qatar avait décidé de
faire une fond d'intervention pour les
banlieux françaises à partir du moment
où le gouvernement a dit d'accord mais
ce sera du 50 50 et même du 50 plus une
voix sur 50 % j'ai rien contre on est en
mal de capital et donc ça ça ne me gêne
pas à condition que encore une fois ce
soit surveillé géré et fait dans la
philosophie de la République française
bacharassad
ben Bachar alAssad c'est intéressant
parce que justement ça montre combien
aujourd'hui il est difficile de faire du
noir et blanc comme on faisait à
l'époque de la guerre froide parce que
tout à coup on se dit mais lequel des
lequel laquelle des solutions est la
pire et quand on ne sait pas quelle est
la solution la pire le mieieux c'est de
pas intervenir on a jamais réussi à
arrêter une guerre civile par une
intervention extérieure militaire
Kaddafi Kaddafi Kaddafi j'avoue que là
aussi on était dans la même situation
personne ne pouvait véritablement
prévoir la décomposition du pays une
fois sa
disparition une fois qu'ils auraient
disparus donc il y a eu une espèce de
mèche qui a été allumée on ne savait pas
quelle était l'intensité de l'explosion
mais on revient sur quelque chose qui
devrait être un ces constats qu'il faut
faire aujourd'hui c'est que il faut
cesser de surutiliser l'outil militaire
quand on ne veut pas se donner la peine
d'analyser politiquement John
mccen c'est le fabricant de
frites Laurent Fabius ben Laurent Fabius
c'est intéressant parce que c'est une
trajectoire de ces type qui justement
aujourd'hui font partie des
néoconservateurs arrivés au pouvoir euh
qui ne se refuse à tout réexamen de sa
propre politique euh alors que les
Américains sont en train de normaliser
leur relation à l'Iran pour des raisons
d'ailleurs qu'on comprend hein parce
qu'on a besoin des Iraniens pour
résoudre la crise en Afghanistan au
Pakistan en Liban en Syrie en Irak ce
qui est quand même pas mal on a toujours
un président qui campe seul au à l'avant
du Titanic en disant je su le mettre du
monde bon le problème c'est que le
Titanic vous connaissez la suite de
l'histoire hein allez dernière question
si vous aviez laissé si vous aviez à
laisser une bouteille à la mer sur
Internet on va vous rendre mortel
aujourd'hui si vous aviez à laisser une
bouteille sur Internet pour les jeunes
générations pour les jeunes générations
est-ce que vous avez un conseil à leur
donner quelque chose pour maximiser leur
défense intellectuelle contre la
dialectique de la
novlangue c'est une question extrêmement
difficile hein parce que il y a déjà eu
une première un premier slogan qui a eu
une extraordinaire popularité c'était le
indignez-vous de C Fanel moi je leur
diraiis travailler étudier regardez
apprenez c'est vraiment la seule
protection qu'on est aujourd'hui contre
cette espèce de flot d'information
immédiate donnez-vous le temps de
réfléchir reporterend réfléchir plagir
oui puis surtout apprendre apprendre
apprendre c'est ça qui est cette espèce
de notre société à ce site paradoxal
qu'on peut se dire mais à 20 ans vous
pouvez être milliardaire si vous devenez
footballeur ou chanteur de charme vous
devenez tout à coup milliardaire donc si
vous voulez là il y a une dégradation de
la connaissance ces trajectoires là sont
des trajectoires incroyablement
séduisantes pour des jeunes or on ne
pourra pas jamais faire l'économie de
savoir quand même le jour où on se
trouve face à la difficulté quelle
posture prendre regardez pendant la
l'occupation un scandale pendant
l'occupation c'est facile aujourd'hui de
dire il fallait être dans la résistance
mais les gens qui étaient face à ce
problème là Ctait 3 ou 9 % de la
population fallait qu'ils ait cette
espèce de distance critique qui faisait
qu'un degul qui était pourtant un type
de droite et voire d'extrême droite ass
c'est monarchiste au début décide que la
France c'était autre chose que Pétin et
on a de l'autre côté un Pétin qui avait
aéolé de sa gloire et cetera qui pouvait
séduire la majorité de la population
parce que c'était le sauveur de la
France cette espèce d'examen individuel
qui fait qu'on se positionne sur des
valeurs après une
connaissance c'est ça le véritable défi
de l'homme indépendant aujourd'hui
Pierre connaiss ça merci merci à
[Musique]
vous à partir du moment où on autorise
les opérateurs à faire ce qu'ils veulent
sur le réseau
en fait on les autorise à modifier la
société on les autorise à modifier la
façon dont les gens interagissent de
mieux en mieux o il y a de plus en plus
d'opportunités de plus en plus de savoir
et de talent et de plus en plus de
solutions et de plus en plus de capitaux
pour des projets c'estàdire que ce qui
manque à l'heure actuelle que dans
beaucoup de pays on fait évoluer le
cadre institutionnel pour inclure la
société civile dans le débat et on est
très loin de faire ça en France je pense
c'est même un peu la terreur des
institutions